so we have the some negative 50 plus
negative 44 plus negative 38 all the way
we keep adding all the way we get to
2038 and then 2044 so see if you can
pause this video and evaluate this sum
so let's work through this together and
let's just think about what's going on
so the first term here is negative 15
then we go to negative 44 so the second
term is negative 50 plus 6 and then the
third term we add 6 again negative 44
plus 6 is negative 38 and we go all the
way to here we keep adding 6 and to go
from 2038 to 2044 to get to that last
term we add 6 once again and so each
successive term is just 6 more than the
term before it so we are dealing right
over here this is an the sum is an
arithmetic series it's a sum of an
arithmetic sequence each term is 6 more
is a constant amount is the constant
amount more than the term before that so
we know how to take the sum of an
arithmetic sequence we know that if we
have if we're taking the sum of the
Meuse in a new color just to have a
little bit of variety on the screen if
we're taking the sum of of the first n
terms of an arithmetic sequence or if
we're taking or for evaluating the first
n terms of an arithmetic series I could
say it's going to be the first term plus
the last term divided by 2 you could
view this as the average of the first
and the last term's times the number of
terms that we're dealing with so over
here we know what our first and last
terms are we know this right over here
that is a 1 and this is our last term
2044 so that is our a sub n so the other
question is is well what is n how many
terms do we actually deal with and to
think about that we just say well how
many times do we have to add 6 to go
from negative 50 to 2044 well 2044 minus
negative 50 minus negative 50 well
that's the same thing as 2044
50 or 2094 and the whole reason I
calculated this is I want to figure out
how far do I have to go from negative 52
2044 I have to I have to go up 50 just
to get back to zero and then go up
another 2044 it's have to go 50 just to
get back to zero then go up another 2044
so I have to go up by 2094 so if I'm
going if I'm adding six on every term
how many times do I have to add six to
increase by 2094 well let's just take
2094 and divide it by six to figure that
out so 6 goes into 20 3 times 3 times 6
is 18 subtract 20 minus 18 is to bring
down the 9 6 goes into 29 4 times 4
times 6 is 24 subtract 29 minus 24 is 5
bring down the 4 we have a 54 6 goes
into 54 9 times 9 times 6 is 54 and we
are done so to go from negative 52 2044
I have to add 6 to 349 times so I had it
once I add it twice and then this right
over here this is the 340 ninth time
that I'm adding 6 so how many terms do I
have now you might be tempted to say 349
terms but really have 349 plus 1 terms
you have the 349 for every time you
added 6 so this is the first time you
added 6 second time you've added 6 all
the way to the 349th time you added 6 so
let me make it clear this this is
actually a this is the 349th time added
6 to get to this but we haven't kind of
the first term just yet so we're going
to have so we have 300 then we have the
first term and then we add 6 349 times
so we have 350 terms in this sum so in
this case n is going to be equal to 350
n is equal to 350 and so we can say the
sum of the first 300 I do this enough
I'll do this in green the sum of the
first 350 terms is going to be equal to
the average of the first and last term
so negative 50 plus 2004
thirty-four over two over two times
three hundred and fifty so let's see
negative 50 plus two thousand forty four
that's going to be what 2094 two
thousand ninety four divided by two x
times three fifty so let's see if I just
take so this is going to be a COS right
this is two hundred and ninety four
times
let's see 350 divided oh sorry
294 one of my my brain is not working mm
this is two this is actually this is
gonna be nineteen ninety-four my brain
really really wasn't working a little
while ago so this is going to be
nineteen ninety four divided by two
times three hundred and fifty and so
let's see three hundred fifty divided by
two is 175 so this is going to be one
thousand nine hundred one thousand nine
hundred ninety four ninety four times
175 which is equal to and I'll use a
calculator for this one so let me get
the calculator out
so one thousand not nine hundred ninety
four times 175 gives us three hundred
forty-eight thousand nine hundred fifty
three hundred forty-eight thousand nine
hundred and fifty and we could express
this in Sigma notation now now that we
know what the N is I mean we've we found
our answer this is what we were looking
for but just in case you're curious we
could write this as a sum from let's say
K is equal to 1 to K is equal to 350 of
let's see we could write this as as
negative fifty negative 50 plus six
times K minus one because the first term
we don't want to actually add the six
and then the last term we want to add
the six 349 times which we saw so we're
going to 49 times and there you have it
that's this this arithmetic series
written in as Sigma notation so
hopefully hopefully you enjoy
pardon my my little mental error earlier
I don't know what was going on in my
brain